hey guys it's Johanna here so with our
busy and fast-paced lifestyle nowadays
most of us barely have any time to COO
so are you guilty of not planning or
prepping your meals and you tend to eat
out all the time eating out frequently
especially when you're limited to
unhealthy food choices can affect your
health and it can also lead to weight
gain if you're watching your weight and
want to eat healthier your best bet is
to prep your own meals because you will
know exactly what goes into your meal
and how much you're eating I love
sandwiches and wraps as my lunch to go
because it is quick convenient and
simple to eat whether you're at work
school or even more traveling the thing
about store-bought pre-tax sandwiches is
that they aren't always the healthiest
better to contain a lot of hidden fat
and calories from butter mayo and cheese
so I'm going to share with you three
delicious and healthy sandwich and wrap
recipes all of these take less than ten
minutes to prep they are all under 350
calories and very high in nutritional
values remember sandwich and wraps are
not boring or tasteless use these five
steps to build a healthy and delicious
sandwich the first step is to choose
low-calorie bread for portion control
use medium / thick sliced bread choose
wrap or pita bread which tends to
contain less calories in comparison to
bagels bagels or roles the second step
is to add high quality protein such as
grilled or shredded chicken turkey
salmon tuna eggs
and more be very careful with code cuffs
as many pre-packed luncheon meats tend
to be loaded with fat sodium and other
preservatives the third step is to pile
on the vegetables eating a healthy
sandwich it doesn't mean it has to be
thin in fact making sandwiches thick by
piling on lots of vegetables vegetables
will make a more filling sandwich and
visually you think you're eating more
without adding lots of calories the
following step is to add healthy fat yes
we should reduce or avoid at the
unhealthy fats such as butter or meal
instead replace with healthy fats such
as avocado olive oil your good nuts
seeds or even cheese and in healthy fats
will add more flavor and texture to your
sandwich and it will take longer for
your body to digest
hence keeping you full in for much
longer yes they are still high in
calories so consumed in moderation and
the final step is to flavor your
sandwich fillings with herbs and spices
instead of adding high calorie sources
of the spices making your food so tasty
without adding extra fat so with these
five basic steps you can keep
experimenting with different fillings
and you won't eat the same sandwich over
and over again so let's start by making
my favorite sweet chicken sandwich the
ingredients for the filling are 1 and
1/2 cup of chicken breast boiled and
shredded cut a cup of dried cranberries
roughly chopped half a red onion sliced
into cubes 1 medium tomato sliced into
cubes 1 tablespoon of finely grated
Parmesan cheese and lettuce please as
much as you like to make the dressing
use quarter cup of plain yogurt half a
tablespoon of honey and 1 teaspoon of
or cider vinegar in a large bowl combine
shredded chicken cranberries red onion
tomato and Parmesan cheese set aside in
a separate bowl combine all the dressing
ingredients plain yogurt honey and apple
cider vinegar mix until well blended
pour the dressing mixture over the
chicken mixture and toss until evenly
coated place generous amount of lettuce
leaves on 1 sliced bread add the mixture
and sandwich it with another layer of
lettuce leaves and thread
so besides adding more greens into your
diet the purpose of layering with
lettuce leaves on each side of the bread
is to protect the sandwich from going
soggy each serving with 2 million sliced
bread contain about 321 calories the
yogurt dressing is a great mayor
substitute to make your sandwich feeling
creamy and rich and I like to combine
sweet cranberries with savory chicken to
satisfy my sweet craving so try it out
if you like Asian flavored food with
lots of spices that I'm sure you will
like my vegan spiced Korean chip is rap
the ingredients you need are one can of
chickpeas rinsed and drained 1 large red
bell pepper diced into cubes put a cup
of dried cranberries roughly chopped
quarter cup of cashew nuts juice from
half a lemon 1 garlic clove diced half
an onion diced half a tablespoon of
olive oil one teaspoon of curry powder
half a teaspoon of ground cumin and salt
and pepper to taste in a pan kids olive
oil over medium-high heat
and onion garlic and spices curry powder
and cumin lightly stir fry for 2 to 3
minutes and to fragrant the mix in the
chickpeas bell pepper cranberries and
lemon juice salty for another three to
four minutes and two ingredients are
warm and well combined reduce to medium
heat and toss in the cashew nuts season
with salt and pepper continue to cook
education adds a slightly brown and all
ingredients are coated in spices set
aside to cool down take one whole ring
wrap and place one fifth of the filling
near the center roll up tightly and wrap
it in foil this wrap is bursting with
flavors you're getting protein from the
chickpeas healthy fat from the cashew
nuts and sweet energy boost from the
cranberries it is great to be eaten both
warm and chilled so make several wraps
ahead wrap it in foil and store it in
the fridge if you let it chill that
happen it's straight from the fridge if
you look in warm a real heat in the oven
before serving one serving with a
medium-sized homemade wrap has about 306
calories if you prefer a creamier
texture you can always add the yogurt
dressing from a previous recipe and
finally my favorite breakfast which can
also be the perfect lunch to go creamy
avocado egg sandwich only two main
ingredients two whole eggs hard-boiled
and sliced into cubes and half an
avocado and of course we want to boost
the flavor by adding one tablespoon of
parsley roughly chopped juice from half
a lemon
a handful of rockets and salt and pepper
to taste in a bowl match the avocado
then mix in the eggs parsley lemon juice
and season with salt and pepper combine
well let's assemble the damaged top a
good amount of rockets on the bread
spread half of the avocado of egg
mixture evenly then top with more
Rockets and another slice of bread done
avocado is incredibly popular among
health-conscious people because it is
very nutritious creamy and rich in
flavor which is great to be added in all
kinds of recipes it contains more
potassium than banana
very high in fiber and packed with
healthy fats any on the other hand is a
very convenient source of protein so the
simple avocado X average is yummy
healthy and has about 300 and 13.5
calories so guys here are some useful
tips or the filling recipes I've shared
can be stored in a container and it will
last up to three days in the fridge so
it makes it very convenient for you to
prep your lunch three days ahead to keep
your sandwich and wrap fresh I would
recommend even assembling it the night
before or in the morning or you can pack
the sandwich filling separated from the
sliced bread and assemble it at work or
school this will also prevent your
sandwich from going soggy and you can
even reduce it to one sliced bread by
eating your sandwich open-faced so take
a few minutes in the morning all the
nights before and make yourself a
healthy sandwich for lunch by investing
only 10 minutes to prep your bill you
will see and feel that
to your body health and even save money
be sure to try all these recipes and let
me know which is a favorite in the
comments below share your pictures on
Facebook and Instagram all the best